jazz is freedom jazz is equality jazz is
human jazz is raw everyone who plays has
their own identity i just love the fact
that in this music having a unique voice
was always so welcomed i'm beerusa
chatterjee i'm 20 years old and i'm a
jazz musician
[Music]
bruce is probably one of uh let me start
that over because it's not probably
bruce is definitely one of the world's
leading saxophonists and to be able to
study with someone like that means the
world to me
i grew up with a single mom and having
someone like bruce a father figure in my
life is something that i'm grateful
every day to have
hi i'm bruce williams i'm a jazz
musician and a mentor i really believe
mentoring young people is key to the
survival of any art form i first met
bruce at jazz house kids which was
founded by jazz vocalist melissa walker
melissa's husband is world-renowned
bassist christian mcbride who has a
mentor of his own mr lovett hines
[Music]
remember we have to do what
pop the f key
ready
one two ready play
performing in front of a crowd still to
this day i get this level of nervousness
and i think that's because it's so
unpredictable disease is a very unique
room i think nerves that's a good thing
jazz is a great american art form
so on stage you're representative of
that
i think when people think of jazz they
automatically think of sophistication
whenever bruce walks into a room he's
always super well put together and just
commands respect
well the suit is classic
if you look good you feel like you sound
good
being dressed in something that you feel
comfortable in and that you feel great
in is super important
you do represent the american fabric of
the music
playing at such a historic venue is
definitely a huge deal for me just
knowing that on the very same stage that
i'm playing some of my biggest idols
have played i never take it for granted
whenever i'm at disney's it's just a
very surreal experience
[Music]
jazz is freedom jazz is equality jazz
was one of the first outlets that really
broke the color barrier and just allowed
people to get on one bandstand and make
beautiful art together i think that's
really what makes me so passionate about
it
i'm very proud of him he's become like a
real young man you know someone i trust
i treat him like a son
from the bottom of my heart i really
love him i owe so much to bruce and
just know that i'm super grateful to
everything you've done and all the time
you've given me
[Music]